[Music]
how dangerous is lady gaga how dangerous
and we're talking to someone who's
who's expert who is a professional in in
this kind of music
industry i've been in the film industry
for 20 years and i finally now got that
budget to go
we're going to do a feature this is
going to go out mainstream in the
cinemas blah blah all over the world
distribution
they're trying to find what we've got
but we got it and then they're trying to
find what we've got and
the puff daddies of the world listen to
them they're like this dunya is just
where this passes by in this world and
uh
you can see it's like how can you expect
the heart to be content
if you don't have a relationship with
the one who created the heart
i'm sin like um i'm ashamed of my bad
deeds but that would never
stop with getting on my knees like i'm
not doing good
i like going to bring good to me that's
this is a simple math
by trying to fix your problems the way
of fixing your because another problem
is going to kind of
a way of fixing your problem by fixing
that heart fixing relationship with a
lot
and you can handle problems i never
lose hope never lose hope no one else
never loses
myself if i can't turn to allah to him
if allah can't help me
no one can help me man helps that woman
move a hijab from there today
the iman does that like not with and so
but we're not going through some
struggles i can imagine oh
major struggles maybe whoever created me
show me a sign guide me
[Music]
a long time but reunited guess who's
here with me so i'm
going to come salive having the little
it's a pleasure bro just like it was
yesterday huh
imagine that yeah i always remember we
shared a room we gotta pray for you
together and then we were on
on our different paths but allah got a
plan
he's the best of planners we're back
together again that's right that's right
how's it been alhamdulillah lots
happening man a lot's happened
since uh more of the same more traveling
um telling that story of my conversion
to islam in so many different cities i
found myself in like australia
south africa malaysia all over the world
like
yeah just working with the young people
we got the spot project now so we built
orphanage and gambia so yeah
and good work let's talk about a few of
the the points you you just uh you spoke
about
having this dunya in your hand most
people they have it in their heart
yeah and then that's when you're doomed
yeah talk about that
i just feel like um i know it's
it's easier to notice the situation and
the state we're in
because of how the worlds move forward
like social media
so with things like social media it's
like it's more clear now you can
actually
see like the state yeah just reading
comments
alone you can see the state of the
people like when you read comments
because you just think wow wow wow is
this what we're on this is what we're
upon
just the comments like even if i saw
something um
someone doing something terrible i don't
know if i could comment something rude
to them like you just
i just feel like being a religious
person and being a rude person
doesn't mix regardless of what it is and
then see so much anger so much rude
and so much people chasing like fame
yeah
chasing fame everyone wants to be famous
this is my youtube hey guys hey guys
good morning guys
it's like who's these guys you're
talking to like there's this fame thing
and i'm thinking
we're chasing so much in this life and
um yeah let's check myself one day so i
was doing that rhyme
i was freestyling and i was just like um
like i remember when it was so simple
and i don't know if it's because of like
the snapchats and the instagrams but i
remember that's why i was like
the love bring us back to how we was in
the start yes how we was in the start
like keep this junior in our hands and
not in our hearts like
this dunya is just we're just passes by
in this world
and uh you can see that some people are
it's like
it's damaging all of us we all need to
protect all of us
myself as well definitely we have to
constantly be renewing our intentions
and
remember what what the goal is yeah to
move out of the way and just point
people
towards allah towards the creator not us
but towards allah you mentioned also
celebrities and specifically you're
talking about because you have a lot of
those people out there
that and that's what's important having
the right intention a
not to pick on sisters anyone in
particular or brothers but this was
particularly he had mentioned like
a lot of um youth they look up to let's
say a celebrity
youtuber and she's got the you know
she's doing the fashion hijabs or
whatnot
and next to you know like wow and
they're empowered next you know she
takes it off
yeah yeah now you attached your heart to
her and now
she takes it off what do you do now yeah
very dangerous very very dangerous and
this is why
even myself i used to a lot of my albums
i used to say things like i'm not a role
model
because like like don't follow us as the
people like don't
look don't put us on that pedestal like
we're just humans
like we're not um like one of the
scholars said we're not the nba like we
can't
today we might say something tomorrow we
can we can change that thing we're just
human so
and now this is it we've gone moved on
with the time but this is where we've
got a task because
there's the scholars the people with the
knowledge another man has graduated from
medina university amazing knowledge he
can benefit all of us
he's got 300 followers online but i know
a girl
who's good at plucking eyebrows and
doing this i don't know contour
lining on the cheeks she's got three
million
so there's two things it shows that what
we're interested in
and what we're really inspired by and
another thing is
how are we gonna build that bridge that
gap between those people of knowledge
and the audience why are they talking
yes we need to get away where they want
to listen to that
and win them back but yeah it's very
dangerous because and
and what seems to happen is okay this
sister's like hey guys hey guys hey guys
and then she's taking her and everyone
love i love you i love you i love you
she's a hijabi i look up to you then she
takes it off
and it's like now you're leading people
astray but it's like
then we're attacking her and saying
you're leading all these people astray
which is quite understandable but then
she's depressed and wants to commit
suicide
she's not on this like we so we've got
to be careful in every way yeah
in every way and i think the main thing
is building up everyone's faith
because i just feel like we're
we're pointing out who's doing wrong and
who's doing right
and what's halal and what's good and
what's bad and they're bad and we're
good and these are good and they're bad
and we're bad at it
but if everyone builds up their iman
their faith it helps us stay away from
the bad and run towards the good
the iman helps us follow the rules the
iman helps that woman
move a hijab from there today the iman
does that like not
and so but we're not focusing on the
amanda faith we're just focusing on get
your back
so i think we need to like even i shall
may allow you please where she said if
they came to us with the rules straight
away we'd have ran away
first we learned faith our faith became
good
then it was easier to follow the rules i
think we need to figure out a way
of spreading this faith this man like
building it up and then i think we'll
have
those youngsters once they got property
man they won't look up to these
youtubers
yeah they'll start looking up to people
who they meant to look up to
the youtubers once they got property man
they will start fearing
that because i know me one of the
scariest things is fame
i go to these events and it's scary
it's scary that's why i try and talk
about it so much in my eyes
yeah like yeah so because that's a
medicine back for yourself now because
you're reminding yourself
for your purpose why you're here but you
are someone that can obviously identify
with the culture with the youth with the
adult it's not just the youth it's the
adults
and people who are going through that
lifestyle that
chasing like you were saying that you
were amazed that
you left that lifestyle yeah i was there
being done that we understand that we
understand that
what that tastes like and then we
understand what the deen
what the dean is and what it tastes like
and the substance that it carries how
that is
is basically an empty shell it's it's
you can never fill the void
in the heart by giving it the dunya
but when you have that iran and you have
that connection with your creator
that fills the void how how do you like
to to bridge
now when obviously former christian in
the music industry
how dangerous it is for someone coming
in i i me personally
when i came in i started to make slow
steps obviously but
a lot of the poisons you have like i
call it std spiritually transmitted
diseases
how dangerous is lady gaga how dangerous
and we're talking to someone who's
who's expert who is a professional in in
this kind of music
industry how dangerous is i mentioned
lady gaga
because i don't know who's the most
popular right now right yeah yeah yeah
but
if you want to grow in this iman if you
want to grow in your deen
how quickly should you start to get rid
of it and replace it maybe with things
like like
what you're singing you know the the
rhines without all the
you know all of that crazy stuff and
i think um
all right what i can say not saying how
dangerous they are but one thing you
notice is
they're lady gaga's or whatever the
world they're looking for faith
they're trying to find something okay so
they're trying to find what we've got
but we got it and then they're trying to
find what we've got and that's what's
madden is that we're trying to find what
they've got
but they are those people i'm telling
you all those select they're all like
you listen to them speak the puff
daddies of the world listen to them
they're like
i want to meditate or i want to go to
like thailand and do
they're all trying to find peace they're
talking everyone's trying to find out
you can see that
people yeah yeah yeah all of them all of
them do research on them watch their
interviews don't listen to their music
watch their interviews
and you'll hear they're all looking for
a way out
or trying to find peace or trying to
find inner peace
all looking for it everyone's searching
for this inner peace and it's like we've
got the gem
we've actually already got that gem but
we don't value it like we don't
understand the value of this gem
but they're all looking for that inner
peace all of them all of them all of
them like
and that's why we need to value what we
already have like
definitely we already have that gym
value the treasure before you lose it
because it's easy a man will take a few
steps
lose his soul she'll lose her soul it's
that easy right that's it a heart
everyone in this world just wants to be
happy everyone just wants to be happy
and the problem with us is we look for
happiness in all the wrong areas we
don't actually know what will make us
happy we think our desires will make us
happy
but there's a god above us that knows
what will really make us happy
and the truth is that lord that created
us and everything around us
it's like how can you expect the heart
to be content
if you don't have a relationship with
the one who created the heart yes like
you're searching in all the wrong areas
absolutely there's simplicity it's like
um
yeah there's simplicity in it we need to
more focus on our relationship with that
god
and that will solve all the problems
yeah that also
a couple more things you come into this
dean and it's not as allah the creator
is telling us
uh do you think that you're just going
to say i believe and you're not going to
be tested
there's many challenges people come in
inspecting expecting it to be a smooth
ride
calamities hit they don't they don't use
the tools of islam and then a lot of
people
they unfortunately they leave out but
you you stayed in you
you've stayed through the struggles so
tell us
what are some of the things that helped
you as a new muslim to get through many
of the challenges you went through some
struggles i can imagine ah
major struggles major struggles like um
you know what helped me it's like
i'm on this journey and i feel like it's
keeping that faith in allah like you
know what it is
i remember listening to things i don't
know listen
it's like allah is how your his servant
sees him
so i'm saying to myself all right i'm
gonna use my i believe
you are the most merciful you are
of the giving and so when i'm in
situations
i don't doubt a lot i see some people
they're like
they lose hope it's like i speak to
someone and like
but my father passed away and this has
happened and they lost hope like they're
not gonna i said what you're not gonna
pray
ah if did i i never lose hope
no matter what i don't lose hope i just
thinking a lot
get me out of this no matter what i've
done i said the end the traveler
i've sinned like um i'm ashamed of my
bad deeds but that would never stop with
getting on my knees like
i could do a sin i never think that arc
i'm not good like
some people sin and they don't want to
go back to the most they feel like
they're dirty i can't go too much i
can't pray i
never lose hope never lose hope no one's
like
never losing to myself if i can't turn
to a lot to him if allah can't help me
no one can help me regard that and some
people think i know some guys like
they're going through problems at home
they're struggling and he's like he's
going back to the streets to make money
right he hits the struggle goes back to
the street goes back to the streets but
he's got all good excuses mom's sick and
this is bad
and we've got to pay the bills so i'm
going to hit the streets i'm going to
sell these i'm going to do criminal
activities to make money
i said okay so that's going to help what
so you think that
you don't think that allah is going to
help you you think that
you doing because my thing is this you
see when i sin i think that
i await the um punishment like i think
that if i'm not doing good
i like going to bring good to me that's
this is a simple maths really
so like i just think if i do good allah
will bring good to me if i do
bad allah is going to bring bad to like
not but in that kind of ways how i look
at it
i'm thinking you can't be on the streets
doing all of that and i think allah is
going to
you're going to end up ruining yourself
even more you're not going to fix your
problems by trying to fix your problems
the way of fixing your because another
problem is going to kind of
the way of fixing your problem by fixing
that heart fixing relationship with
allah and you can handle problems
then you can handle anything like i feel
like when you've got a good relationship
with god allah
you can handle anything that this world
this dunya throws at you because it's
dunya is not in your heart
it's just in your hands so you can
handle everything that it throws at you
so that's kind of one way
an experience though i don't want to
talk like because experience is a great
teacher so
i've gone up and gone back down so when
you experience that drop
then the next time you get up your
experience has taught you
so i don't want to look like anyone like
i've had to experience his ups and downs
i went through them days where um money
becomes hard
and like i'm battling with the film
industry a lot
so i went for a stage where i said i
won't make movies again
like nah because the movies are this
damn too religious enough to be in
movies
and then i was like they offered me a
movie uh 2012 i think it was like six
years seven years ago and it was like
but the scenes you're in there's nothing
haram in you know like so then i'm like
okay maybe i'll do that movie because
the money's
going through my battles and then it's
like everything that comes with it and
the fame and then a youngster says to me
pulls me in the mosque and he's like
this is how the kids looking at me it's
like because in the film i'm acting as a
bad guy
i'm thinking yeah yeah but the kid got
you thinking
yeah kid was about seven years old and
he came up to me and said that
i was like so i go for my own tests we
all go through tests we all go through
tests but
that's why i say like you just gotta
have that faith in allah and now
look at that i always say in travel at
the same track i say
you give up something for a lie replaces
it with something better i remember when
i said all right you know what that's it
now i'm not gonna do no more movies like
that
make them things and i started doing
certain good things that
maybe in charlotte accepted in the path
of allah
and then i get um funding to do a proper
feature film
like a big release feature film
that i've always wanted to do that is
within the boundaries like no music
no nudity no swearing no
no scenes of sexual nature not even a
swear word
in this film like and about a revert to
islam
my story and i was just like this is
what i always wanted to do because i
make film for a living but i've never
wanted to do them
i want to utilize it but there's no
money and that's why you got muslims
like allah wood them trying to make like
films
the dollar films but it's not real films
like with real backing and real money
like you're not going to compete with
the slumdog millionaires and
you know city of guys like these films
because it's low budget
and i've been in the film industry for
20 years and i finally now
got that budget to go we're going to do
a feature this is going to go out
mainstream in the cinemas blah blah all
over the world distribution
and like so a lot you have to have faith
in a lot
you have to never give up never lose
hope uh so where can people see this
film that's coming out
so um this film is done already
no no no we're in pre-production now
we've been in pre-production for the
last couple of months
we start shooting in january yeah and we
won't finish shooting till march
so we're shooting for like seven weeks
some in london
some abroad i don't want to give to but
yeah he shot half in the uk and half in
another country
and then we're going to edit in stage so
it won't be till
the end of 2019 end of the summer we'll
try it for summer 2019 you know the end
of 2019 you'll be out
and inshallah it will be a a worldwide
release
in the cinemas so look out for a muslim
bilal
here here on the dean show and last
piece of advice someone never heard the
name of allah
someone is tuning and just came from a
rock concert hip-hop concert and they're
depressed they've been doing all sorts
of things they're tuning in
they like what we have to say where do
you recommend people start
i think um you should just call up call
us and say whoever made me
whoever made me whoever created me
show me a sign guide me and show me a
sign
beautiful and allah is going to guide
them isn't that simple that's your
homework
be sincere be genuine and ask the
creator the heavens and earth the
ultimate the reality the one who created
you to guide you
thank you thank you
be